I want to take a little bit of a
departure from looking at specific
numbers and ask the question how do you
measure numbers this was one of the most
challenging things I came across
studying maths at uni was this notion of
how to measure mathematically measure so
this is what I'm going to do I'm going
to show you the real number line yeah
you're familiar with that right so think
about this right this is the real number
line it's there in your head so here's
my question what's the distance between
3 & 4 what's the measure how long is
that section well when how did you get
that because I know the number that I
need to add to 3 to get to 4 yeah is 1
okay that's good
so you so you you know have a number so
you know the answer basically you're
saying yeah yeah ok ok imagine you
didn't know the answer so imagine this
is the first time you've ever tried to
measure the distance between 3 & 4 what
would you do like I'd make a piece of
wood the distance between 0 & 1
all right and I would take it to 3 & 4
there you go how many of them do I have
to put on that okay that's good that's
good I like that okay that's good it's
actually good that you brought in
reality because that's going to really
bite you it's going to really bite you
but that's cool that's cool I like the
fact you said that so basically you said
okay well I'm going to look at a bit of
a number line which I know what the
length is because it starts at 0 okay
and you're going to go and drag it over
until you measure it but another way you
could do it okay is you could say this
number take that number so you're
comfortable with that you know that that
distance there okay is 43 now this is
what's called naive and it's not a
put-down okay it's naive it's a naive
way of measuring numbers but okay I'm
hopefully going to take you down the
rabbit hole now three point five is a
point yeah
it's a point right there I'm going to
put a little kind of little bit of chalk
wire around it
okay three point five is a point do you
agree that it exists three and a half
you're happy with that
okay what's the length of three and a
half what's the length of it yeah from
all I need us to give you a length I
need a start point and an end point
known and then I'm just talking about
the point just the point one point so
what's the length of a point point start
have a length
what's another way of saying that three
point five take three point five is zero
we use exactly the same logic that we
used here for the segment of line we're
going to use the same logic for the
point okay now this sounds like I'm
being trivial maybe even annoying but I
am getting somewhere I'm making a point
about points okay because what now is
the length of three to four if we remove
the point three point five what is the
length of that line segment the length
is still one why because the thing you
removed took up no space that's right so
this idea right is that we've got a line
segment three to four okay which is made
up of a continuous set of points I mean
there's only points between three and
four right but if we remove three point
five we haven't changed it we haven't
changed it at all and part of the reason
behind that is because the real number
line has this property that there is no
next number what's the what's the number
after three point five three point five
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero yeah exactly
but even you want you're not even saying
that correctly because the way that we
describe numbers doesn't contain what's
the awesomeness of what's going on here
why is this a problem because we are we
are using stuff that we haven't proved
we're using naive notions of measure
that's why that's a problem we're making
assumptions this almost broke maths
where I'm going with this
it almost broke Matt